la décision était attendue l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire a ouvert la voie hier à
une prolongation de la durée de vie des
réacteurs au-delà de 40 ans à chinon et
saint-laurent-des-eaux la nouvelle est
bien accueillie
en ligne de mire des emplois sauvegardés
en revanche cette annonce l'est beaucoup
moins par les antinucléaires qui
dénoncent un risque aggravé pour la
population reportage à chinon florent
clavel depuis les années 80 elle crache
son nuage de vapeur et cela pourrait
encore durer au moins dix ans de plus la
centrale nucléaire de chinon fait partie
des huit centrales françaises qui
devraient voir leur durée de vie
prolongée de 40 à 50 ans c'est en tout
cas le sens de la dernière note
d'information de l'asn le gendarme du
nucléaire
pour le maire de chinon cette annonce
était attendue
le nucléaire est une des parties de la
dynamique territoriale mais qui est
celle qui a été le fer de lance
aujourd'hui autour duquel on a construit
le modèle donc c'est important de
pouvoir le maintenir
continuer son développement son
exploitation et puis travailler
renouvellement des équipements donc
c'est l'objectif qui est le nôtre en
tout cas et c'est une excellente
nouvelle
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
conditionne la prolongation de vie des
quatre réacteurs chinonais à de lourds
travaux de mise aux normes
trois objectifs éviter une fusion du
coeur du réacteur
améliorer la résistance aux agressions
extérieures comme les inondations ou
intérieure comme les incendies et enfin
consolider la piscine d'entreposage des
combustibles usés des travaux déjà
entamés dans le cadre du grand carénage
auquel edf consacre 45 milliards d'euros
pour ses plus vieilles centrales comme
celle de chinon mais pour le réseau
sortir du nucléaire ce chantier n'est
pas une garantie de sécurité
les cuves de toute façon c'est
impossible de les réparer parce qu'elles
sont inaccessibles sont c'est le coeur
du réacteur est là il est impossible de
faire quoi que ce soit il ya de quoi
être inquiet de toute façon parce que
ben ça veut dire qu'on prolonge les
réacteurs en prolonge la dangerosité
pour être prolongée au delà de 40 ans
chaque réacteur devra subir un quatrième
réexamen de sûreté
une inspection qui connaît souvent des
retards c'est le cas chinon où les
réacteurs auront déjà atteint 42 voire
44 ans